Liegen wir einem gigantischen Physikalischen
Irrtum auf?
Demnach wäre eine vollkommen neue Physik
nötig, um die Größe des Universums zu bestimmen.
Denn die variiert je nach Größe der Hubble-Konstante.
Denn die ist je nach Messung gar nicht konstant.
Und Kosmologen und Kosmologinnen aus den USA
sorgen jetzt für gewaltigen Aufruhr.
Wie das Forschungsteam auf die These kommt,
die alles umschmeißt.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann und nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
- herzlich willkommen!
Astronomie-Teams konnten mit ihren Teleskopen
bisher Licht einfangen, das sich aus fernsten
Galaxien vor rund 13 Milliarden Jahren zu
uns auf den Weg gemacht hat.
Können wir deswegen also davon ausgehen,
dass der Durchmesser des Kosmos also 26 Milliarden
Lichtjahre groß ist?!
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass sein “Rand”
in jeder Richtung etwa 13 Milliarden Lichtjahre
entfernt, wäre dies die Schlussfolgerung.
Doch diese Rechnung ist dann doch etwas zu
easy.
Schließlich dehnt sich der Kosmos aus - auch
währenddessen das Licht der fernen Galaxien
durch ihn hindurch läuft.
Und wer weiß, vielleicht dehnt er sich ja
am Rnd schneller als mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit
aus.
Das Licht würde uns nicht erreichen.
Und so müssen Forschungsteams weltweit zahlreiche
Faktoren in ihre Berechnungen einbeziehen,
wenn sie sich zu den Ausmaßen unseres Universums
Gedanken machen: beispielsweise die Zusammensetzung
der Materie, die Raumkrümmung und die Geschwindigkeit
der Ausdehnung des Kosmos.
Einige Schätzungen kommen dann auf einen
Durchmesser des Kosmos von bis zu hundert
Milliarden Lichtjahren.
In vielen Berechnungen in diesem Zusammenhang
spielt die sogenannte Hubble-Konstante eine
wichtige Rolle.
Der Astronom Edwin Hubble beobachtete schon
1928, dass sich andere Galaxien von uns weg
bewegen und zwar umso schneller, je weiter
sie von uns entfernt sind.
Der Rückschluss daraus ist, dass es das Weltall
selbst ist, das sich ausdehnt.
Das Hubble-Gesetz beschreibt vereinfacht gesagt,
wie schnell die Geschwindigkeit der Galaxien
mit ihrer Entfernung wächst.
Sie bildet quasi die Basis für unser modernes
Verständnis von unserem Kosmos.
Doch jetzt kommt das große ABER.
Denn nicht alle Methoden zur Messung der Hubble-Konstante
führen zum selben Ergebnis.
Studien zeigen, dass der Wert ein anderer
ist, wenn man uralte Schallwellen genauer
analysiert beziehungsweise, wenn man das Licht
von entfernten Galaxien näher betrachtet.
Mal liegt die Hubble-Konstante bei 67 oder
68, mal bei 73,2.
In manchen Berechnungen erhält man auch ein
Ergebnis, das irgendwo dazwischen liegt.
Die Messungen sind - anders als andere Naturkonstanten
- einfach super aufwendig.
Schließlich basieren sie auf der Entfernung
anderer astronomischer Objekte und ihrer Geschwindigkeit
im Bezug auf uns.
Und dabei handelt es sich eben um wirklich
sehr weit entfernte astronomische Objekte.
Heißt also im Klartext: Genau genommen ist
die Hubble-Konstante - anders als ihr Name
es andeutet - gar nicht konstant.
Und das raubt Forschungsteams weltweit den
Schlaf.
Denn was bedeuten diese Unstimmigkeiten?!
Heißt das etwa, dass die beteiligten Forschungsteams
bisher nicht sauber gearbeitet haben?!
NEIN, sagt jetzt eine neue Studie.
Demnach liegt der Fehler nicht bei den Kollegen
und Kolleginnen aus der Wissenschaft, sondern
beim Universums selbst.
Dazu einer der beteiligten Autoren Lloyd Knox:
“In den letzten zwei Jahren habe ich meine
Annahme, dass sie etwas falsch gemacht haben
könnten, korrigiert.
Stattdessen denke ich: 'Wow, vielleicht haben
sie nichts falsch gemacht.
Vielleicht ist das stattdessen der Hinweis,
auf den ich gewartet habe!“
Knox und sein Team sind überzeugt davon,
dass wir eine neue Physik brauchen, damit
schließlich alle Messergebnisse zur Hubble-Konstanten
übereinstimmen.
Unser bisheriges physikalisches Verständnis
und die darauf basierenden Modelle seien einfach
noch nicht ausreichend!
Somit könnten alle Messungen zur Größe
des Universums stimmen - die Interpretation
dieser Messungen dagegen nicht.
Dabei legen Knox und Co ihren Fokus auf das
Modell des sogenannten Klanghorizonts.
Diese Betrachtung macht es Kosmologen-Teams
möglich, das frühe Universum zu untersuchen.
Demnach haben Schallwellen, die beim Urknall
durch das Vermischen von Licht und Materie
entstanden sind, das Universum zum Klingen
gebracht.
Nach dem Abkühlen der Materie nach etwa 380.000
Jahren stoppte das Klingen, denn die Schallwellen
wurden abgedämpft.
Doch davon blieb etwas übrig und zwar ein
eingefrorenes Wellenmuster im kosmischen Mikrowellenhintergrund.
Und der Klang- bzw.
Schallhorizont definiert die letzten Schallwellen
des Musters.
Und das US-Forschungsteam ist sich sicher,
dass diese aufgenommenen Klänge konkrete
Ableitungen zu den Eigenschaften und Zusammensetzungen
des Universums möglich macht.
Doch dabei sei das bisherige Modell des Klanghorizontes
zu korrigieren.
Laut Knox würden tatsächlich alle Studien
stimmig sein, wenn man die Größe des Klanghorizontes
verkleinern würde.
Eine Erklärung könnte sein, dass das sehr
junge Universum deutlich schneller expandiert
ist als wir es bisher annehmen.
Dann wäre es vereinfacht gesagt auch schneller
“abgekühlt” und der Klanghorizont wäre
früher “eingefroren”.
Und somit auch kleiner als in den bisherigen
Modellen angenommen.
Bei diesen ganzen Überlegungen sind die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler ziemlich optimistisch,
einem noch verborgenen Geheimnis unseres Universums
auf die Spur zu kommen.
Möglicherweise sogar einer Art “neuen Zutat”
im dunklen Sektor, wie Knox es formuliert.
Demnach gibt es möglicherweise eine Art “dunklen
Turbo”, der die Expansion des Universums
beschleunigt hat.
Oder aber die mysteriöse Dunkle Energie hat
mehr als nur eine Form und kann sich im Lauf
der Zeit verändern, so eine weitere Spekulation
des Forschungsteams.
Darüber hatten wir ja berichtet, was ja ein
erstes Indiz für die Stringtheorie wäre.
Und so sollen Teleskope den Klanghorizont
weiter untersuchen.
Dadurch soll dann hoffentlich zeitnah der
wahre Hubble-Wert bestimmt werden können.
Und dies zeigt dann auch, ob die Forschungsteams
bislang unsauber gearbeitet haben oder ob
tatsächlich eine Art neue Physik notwendig
ist.
Dazu Wendy Freedman von der University of
Chicago: “ " Ganz andere These: Das Universum
ist ein Schwarzes Loch - Dafür hier klicken.
Anschauen und Raumzeit Vlog der Zukunft abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!